hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm here with Wade and Tyler and
there's a charity livestream happening
right now for the make-a-wish Foundation
you can look in the description there's
a link to the twitch stream and there's
a link to the make-a-wish Foundation
website where you can find out more
about their great cause they help
fulfill the wishes or maybe even the
last wishes of terminally ill children
who have been in hospitals pretty much
their entire lives and they help them
get that one last wish I'm actually
gonna be fulfilling two wishes very soon
sometime in June I don't know exactly
when but I'm so eager to do this I'm so
excited I never imagined that someone
would ask me to fulfill a wish so I'm
more than happy to do that and we're
more than happy to raise money for this
cause so thank you everybody so much for
watching and also in the stream we will
be announcing or we'll be releasing a
very special video that all three of us
worked on so you got to pay attention
when we're doing that and also we will
be selling this charity shirt with this
design on it it's a beautiful design it
was made by CM HS I am H she did a great
job on it and I'm really grateful that
she decided to make it for us and
specially designed so it could be put on
shirt so you can find that shirt as well
in a link in the description below and
just to answer any questions yes I
shaved yes it was the first time in
about a year yes I do have a baby face
silky smooth so thank you everybody so
much for watching check out the stream
right now and I hope you can stay as
long as you can and I hope you can buy
shirt because for every shirt sold there
will be about fourteen dollars donated
through the charity so we can raise a
lot of money and you can get a very
special reward wear your heart on your
sleeve and become one of the markiplier
heroes it's not in this one
name brand so thank you everybody and
hope to see you there bye